this is a production of Cornell
University so uh yeah I'm going to talk
to you a little bit about my thesis
project I just defended last week so
everything is in motion um I passed so
now you can hear about
my you so um first I want to start
with just a picture of my home this is
uh actually 20 from Amaro but it's
called padura Canyon it's the second
largest canyon in the United States
behind the Grand Canyon and um as you
can see this is a pretty different
climate from itha New York so whenever I
came here it was a quite a culture shock
but um I didn't realized that I lived in
a desert climate whenever I was growing
up because this was my home um and it's
beautiful and diverse and Rocky and so
so windy um so when I came to
Cornell um I came with a lot of
experience that was maybe a little not
traditional so as I said I was born and
raised in the Texas panh handle and uh
the year before I started here at
Cornell I became a beekeeper working at
a local apiary I um learned everything
from this family that decided to teach
me everything they knew and um that
really helped me just ignite my passion
about ecology and Agriculture and seeing
how important honey bees are um made me
start thinking a little more about some
more Dynamic relationships and I'm
specifically really excited about
pollinator interactions with plants so
I'm going to be talking to you a little
bit about that today but this is
basically a video of me um scraping the
wax covering off of a honey frame and
this is all honey and at the apiary you
take these little super frames full of
capped honey that the beads have
collected and made and then you put it
in this kind of giant centrifuge thing
and it waxs all the honey out to this
side um so this was just a view of what
I was doing before I got here but I'll
tell you a little more about what I've
been up to while I've been
here so anyway that's pretty cool that's
what I did for months and months we have
lots and lots of
money um so
okay so I want start just briefly about
um a little bit about strawberry
pollination um I specifically worked on
the day neutral strawberry albian and so
all of the images that I have are albian
um this is a crosssection of the
strawberry flower and strawberries are
perfect flow specifically albian and
they have male and female gamits on the
same flow so whenever you add wind to
the equation you can have really nice
self pollination and there's different
capacities to self-pollinate based on um
cultivar but alvan specifically was read
to have pretty high self-compatibility
so um without a lot of insect
intervention there can be nice set fruit
however if you add insects into the
equations you can also have greater
fruit set uniform fruit appearance and
greater commercial value this is because
uh the true fruit of the strawberry are
the Ain which are these little green
seeds you can see right here and
whenever they're fertilized they begin
to secrete oxin into the receptacle
which is about right here and that's
what enlarges into the red fleshy part
of the strawberry fruit so as you can
imagine if you have a higher percentage
of these AES fertilized you're going to
have more uniform oxin secretion which
will yield a nicer shaped better set
fruit so insects could potentially
really be helpful in Strawberry
pollination I also briefly want to talk
about the difference between honey bees
and Native Bees honey bees are only one
type of be and they are pretty widely um
regarded as a really efficient
pollinator in agricultural systems but
as we continue to learn more about
pollinator interactions we're finding
out that they're not the only player
that's important here so honey bees are
you social meaning that they live in a
colony with Cooperative shared care of
the brute they have one reproductively
active female and um they're often
domesticated meaning they need somebody
to manage their hive in order to have
really high
productivity native bees are kind of a
different story they are mostly solitary
meaning that one female builds her nest
and cares for her own food this is
pretty common in most other animal
kingdom situations uh but one really
important thing here is that they are
wild and very difficult to domesticate
as you can imagine if you're managing
thousands of individual females in
individual nests with only a few grood
per cell um it can be really challenging
to make sure that health is good and
that the females are performing how they
should and so bolstering wild
populations here may be the best way to
go about this so for my thesis I had a
few research aims I wanted to learn how
to best grow day neutral strawberries
specifically albian in New York state by
focusing on propal manipulation and
interro vegetation and I also wanted to
discover what pollinators can or cannot
provide for strawberry in New York
state so I'll go into my experimental
design a little bit um so we've planted
albian in uh ual plastic culture we did
two replications so we replanted each
year in this white plastic and this is
kind of what the field looked like the
first year and we used a split plot rcbd
so everything was completely randomized
and this is kind of a visual of how we
randomized some of our nested treatments
so we started with uh three inter R
cover treatments at the whole plot level
which would be these kind of wide green
white or uh blue pink blocks
and um they all had different qualities
of vegetative growth including exclusion
netting tunnels which are these white
tunnels um they were low tunnels with
really fine mesh netting to exclude any
insect
activity then we had a flowering cover
that was in between the rows of the
plastic and then we had a Barr cover
that was either mowed very very short to
have basically no flowering or we had um
cultivation so it was completely bare
soil and then within these treatments we
had four propal types at the subplot
level and we had um different
developmental cycles that we staggered
so our control plants were dormant be
root crowns that we planted in the field
uh around May each year we had two types
of early start plants those were dormant
bear root crowns that we started um one
month and two months before the infield
planting date in the greenhouse to
establish asou transplants and then we
had plug plants which were daughter
plants from previous mother plants that
we pinned in the greenhouse and then
created transplants that went to the
field the fall prior to the harvest
season so here's a closer look at what
these looked like U on May 6 2022 which
was the first INF field planting date
for the first replicate the berries have
really no vegetative growth um the early
starts have varying amounts of uh
vegetative growth here and then the plug
plants are pretty well established um
and they were planted in August the
previous year or um October for the next
replication so um I broke this up into
two different types of experiments we're
going to talk about the propal type
experiments first and then we'll cover
the intro flowering covers for a second
so the first hypothesis was that
different propil types will flower and
fruit in different patterns and this
ideally will lead to a more consistent
supply of fruit during the season if
anybody's famili amiliar with uh
strawberry production in New York state
currently a lot of Growers grow June
bearing strawberries which usually have
a huge flush of fruit in June and then
not really any availability after that
so to have day neutrals which have the
capacity to fruit continuously as long
as the environment is um desirable could
really expand the season for New York
Growers and uh we also predict that
plants started earlier will be more
productive throughout the season likely
due to to limited sync Source uh
competition so I'm going to start with
um our total yields for 2022 and 2023
these are mean over the months so the
months are at the bottom here this is
2022 this is 2023 and then we have mass
and grams here um along the side and I
just like to note the scaling difference
here this goes up to a little over 600
grams and this goes to about 500 here um
and we do have a little bit different
Fring Cycles though one thing I would
like to point out is that 2023 was a
really challenging growing year um
simply because of the amount of
precipitation we had and precipitation
as you know can uh lead to a lot of
increased fungal bacterial any kind of
disease problems and so we had decreased
yields uh in general but that also
really compromised our marketable yields
um you can also see that it seems that
we're having really high Peaks uh the
purple is the plug type propagules
around August or um a little bit earlier
so the plugs really are performing
really well in these types of
environments and then the early starts
seem to do okay um the red line is the
bare root propuls and it's pretty Stark
how different their performance is
compared to these other types of
propagules so I'd like to move on to
marketable yield this is in 2022 I have
these separated by um cover so we have
the bearr cover exclusion and flowering
cover and then on the side is mean uh
mass marketable mass and really the main
story here is that exclusion cover plugs
and sometimes early starts really
perform significantly better than um the
bare root plants here which performed a
lot worse and um we predict that this is
because there was less SN source compet
and also because the establishment
planting date and um transplants allowed
for maybe some quicker root
establishment you have leaves to provide
better
photosynthate um compared to no
vegetative or active root
growth so for
2023 um our yields are much much lower
um as you can see we barely had any
marketable yield in some of these covers
but really the consistent relationship
here is that plugs and exclusion are
doing significantly better than other
prople types and other uh interro cover
types um I'd also like to point out the
I looked at the newa data for uh the two
years and we looked from the start of
harvest to the end of harvest for both
of years and for 38% of 2022 we had what
was considered a rainy day which was any
amount of precipitation um that's
compared to 57% of the 2023 season just
to show you how much more rain we were
having and so this climate VAR ability
can really compromise our marketable
yields um next I want to talk a little
bit about marketable fruit size by
profit here is 2022 and here is 2023 so
again they're separated into these cover
types and um while there are some
significant differences uh the fruit
size is really stable around uh 10 gr uh
anywhere up to I would say 12 to 13 G
which is a really nice size Berry it's
often about that big maybe the size of
like a small cookie um but it's really
nice to see that no matter what's going
on here we have really nice uh formed
fruit
okay U another thing we were wanted to
look at was season length especially
with cycling these different propagules
to see if we could have a longer Harvest
period and in uh 2022 and 2023 we look
looked at season length based on
marketable yields greater than 100 grams
per subplot each subplot was about 16
Plants and if we're saying that fruits
were about 10 grams each this would only
be 10 fruit per subplot which is a
pretty low threshold to say that we
should pick these fruits um but I think
this is a really nice example of what
weather can do to a season um in
exclusion we had really nice performance
though um the other popes maybe didn't
do so so well the next year however in
bareground and flowering even when the
weather was pretty desirable we had
under two weeks of that amount of
marketable yield which is pretty low and
when you have really really bad weather
conditions you can see we hardly had not
even a week uh worth of picking um and
had a lot of disease and pest problems
so um I think the story here would be to
say that growing strawberries in New
York without any sort of protective
covering or intensive Pest Management is
not a great idea and having some sort of
covering this exclusion netting or low
tunnels can really improve marketable
yields um is the best thing to do here
in New York state Kayla again what what
was the flowering sure yeah the
flowering cover um it I actually have it
on this next
slide there we go yeah so I'll just
cover these quickly and then I I have
this picture of the flowering cover that
I'll explain um and in terms of our
interro cover which I mentioned briefly
and I'm going to talk about more now um
we hypothesized that the strawberry
pollinator Guild is going to change over
the season and it won't be the same um
visitors each time and that the yield
and fruit set and albian are improved
when adjacent floral awards are
available so in 2022 we seated sweet
alysum and 2023 we seated white clover
and these were to complement the native
flowers that were coming up as well so
this was considered the flowering cover
um this is a picture from 2023 of native
German canile coming up in between the
rows um but we also seated these other
plants as a sort of um attractive
pollinator flower to potentially attract
different things that maybe weren't
going to be foraging on these native
plants and we also didn't know the
pollen quality or nectar quantity that
these plants were providing so we
thought by supplementing that may lead
to a more um even pollinator attract
active
environment so um next I want to talk a
little bit about bees on
strawberry for
2022 it was a little bit of a dry season
and um I'm going to go through this
graph kind of slowly because there's a
lot going on here we broke these up into
two different types of cover because our
exclusion cover we're assuming have zero
insect interaction
because there's a net there should be
zero visitations so there are no
visitations recorded on those plots so
the not flowering would be the be ground
with no flower available in between the
rows the flowering would be the seated
alysum or Clover and native plants in
between the rows and um the bottom here
is the date of visitation and then the
visitations are on the side here um and
visitations had to be recorded it in a
very specific way I try to do weekly but
you have to have perfect weather
conditions to have nice pollinator
visitations so that meant barely wi
barely any wind hardly any clouds Sunny
um good air quality which was another
challenge we had in 2023 that we didn't
have in 2022 due to the wildfires um and
the visitation counted if any part of
the bee made Landing contact with any
reproductive part of the flower um which
would signify some sort of pollen
transfer so here uh the black line in
both of these graphs is apis mif or the
European honeybee which is right here
and I also encour uh included this
picture to show kind of how large the
honey be is in relation to the
strawberry flower and um honey bees
carry their pollen on scopa on their
back legs and if you're looking at this
picture besides the static that's
holding pollen onto their fur on their
thorax you're missing a lot of pollen
that's hanging off the back of the
flower and so really if you did have a
lot of honeybee visitations they're not
uh morphologically very well suited for
strawberry pollination it's kind of
hilarious to watch them try to figure
out how to deal with those things
however we have some other bees that are
much more Well Suited and in higher
frequency um in Strawberry like helus
confusus which is this kind of purple
line in both graphs that Peaks usually
around July and kind of um the beginning
of August this is a really nice early
seasoned pollinator that we observed
pretty consistently additionally laog
glossom is this kind of small black uh
be they are very very tiny you can see
it's curled around this one um structure
on the strawberry flower and they often
have a crawling foraging habit so
they'll crawl along all of the pistols
and all over the flower which will drag
pollen all over the uh
all over the female parts of the flower
and that's this pink line so they're
pretty consistent throughout most of the
season but especially in the late season
they seem to be the primary pollinators
and then uh towards later season we have
AO chlorella which is this kind of shiny
green race car v um that's pretty small
they're primitively usocial so they form
really really small hives and um they're
observed in pretty good quantities
towards the end of the season
um so for 2023 we saw a similar sort of
story um however I had one honeybee
visitation on the very last days that I
was recording observations and while I
observed honey bees on the interro flow
jumping over onto strawberries was not a
very common phenomenon um I would say
hardly never when I was doing my
observations except for this one time at
the end of September um um however we
had helus confusus is the purple again
around the same time that it was present
in um 2022 this purple line and then we
had laso glossom which was present for
majority of the season in both of these
uh plots and then what really surprised
me was we had a really large boom in uh
B bumblebees bombus impatience which is
kind of a common bumblebee around this
area um that was really really present
in the late season and then ago florella
in a kind of similar uh relationship
here we I was talking to um Brian
Danforth in the entomology Department
about why we saw bumblebees here and not
last um in the 2022 season and 2022 was
pretty dry early in the season um and
that's when Bumblebees are establishing
their nest and so if you have really
poor vegetative availability and water
you're not going to have very many
bumblebee Queens establish Lish however
in 2023 we had a really wet year which
is very Lush there's lots of water
there's lots of resources and so we
theorize that maybe this productivity
here is because we had a lot more
bumblebee hives established around the
site in East Etha that could lead to
this increase in um activity so that's
another thing to say that weather is a
huge um factor in these sorts of systems
and uh determining what is going on in
terms of
pollinators
so I also collected specimens in 2022
and
2023 uh by sweet netting so every two
weeks I would go and collect anything
that was observed on the strawberry
flower itself and um these tell a pretty
similar story to the visual observations
with pipus confusus comprising 44% of my
collection um that would be these bees
right here and then ago florella AA
doing about
18% um that would be these bees here
and then um the apis MRA or the European
honeybee I only collected two of in 2022
and that's this kind of small orange
slice so this is really nice to show
what percentage of the pollinator Guild
honey bees are comprising and maybe it's
not an awesome idea to rely on honeybees
if you it's not anywhere near majority
of what's actually visiting um these
plants and then in 2023 I collected a
much greater diversity um likely because
of that nice Lush uh rain and vegetative
growth and lots of um ample habitat
establishment but hus confusus was still
the main pollinator uh 29% of my
collection that would be this section
here helus legatus is another heled B um
that comprised a small portion but still
an important portion of this collection
bombus impatience is the Bumblebee which
which is 13% and that would be these big
bees right here um and then apis mif in
this graph is this red slice which was
only 3% of my collection so a pretty
similar narrative here to show that
maybe honeybees are not uh as important
as strawberry as we've previously
thought they
were um I'd also like to point out that
something I didn't mentioned but we
didn't find inter cover or date to be
significant factors for determining
density or diversity of pollinators um
you could likely do a longer study
Heather grab has done some really nice
work on this and and you go into about
five years or more you start to see some
more significant relationships with date
um but on the short term of a study we
didn't really see any uh significant
differences between those covers or
date so I want to go through marketable
yields by cover so these graphs are
organized similarly to the other ones
except these are the four propagule
types and the cover here backround is
red exclusion netting is green and blue
is the flowering cover and uh the mass
here is on the side and the story here
is pretty clear um exclusion performed
significantly better than all of the
other types except for in control it was
a little bit lower um but the exclusion
cover really seems to yield a great
amount of Market fruit uh this is likely
due to some pest protective qualities um
also some weather you don't have
dropping rain which could just um spread
disease and um you also can have a small
microclimate protecting from really
intense sun or um providing a sort of
warming climate for fruit to
develop um also flowering cover while it
seems like a really nice idea for
pollinators can be a huge uh host plant
selection for pests um so while
flowering cover may seem like a good
idea you actually might just be creating
a really nice hotel for all of your
worst nightmare pests to live right next
to your crop so um we had to have a lot
of tarnish plant bug intervention in
addition to some other pests that we
were experiencing um likely because
there was such close availability of
native flowers that they could host
on and then this is 2023 of marketable
yield the marketable yields are much
lower um really because of the
precipitation but the relationship is
still mostly clear especially in the
plug plants in exclusion um and this is
likely because it had protective effects
against the rain dropping onto the
plants and onto the fruit uh we also had
an anthracnose breakout at the end of
the season because of the sheer amount
of
precipitation um so these exclusion
covers while they still were in impacted
by this anthros breakout still we're
yielding um significantly more Mark
gr I also developed a aen fertilization
counting method for fruit sets so
typically people count Ain in a few
different ways you can do um a kind of
quarter section count however many
fertilized Ain you have and then
multiply that to estimate a percentage
of fruit set however that's um really
time consuming really challenging
because these Ain are really small and
if you have clusters of unfertilized
aines like right here that are
impossibly small and not at all
separated it can be really challenging
to get a good estimate on what
percentage you have fertilized when you
can't get a a good count on the total
number of AES you have anyway so what I
wanted to look at we took our exclusion
tunnels and because these are not fully
airtight we were harvesting lifting
covers when we were harvesting I had
help of interns and not everybody closes
the tunnels the same way we were still
having some insect activity so to
mitigate that I exclusion bagged on open
inflorescences to ensure there was no
insect activity on the flowers and that
they were fully self-pollinating
and um this is usually what harvested
fruit would look like and then I would
take these fruits that were considered
marketable cut the skins off put them
through a food processor and then uh we
density sorted these aines so fertilized
are more dense and so they will sink to
the bottom unfertilized AES are much
smaller and less dense because they have
no developing embryo so they'll float so
um we did individual fruits from a
variety of different propuls within the
exclusion covers and manually counted
all of these to come up with some
fertilization proportions to show what
was needed to have a really nicely fruit
uh set
fruit so here's the proportions from
2022 and uh 2023 here um what I would
like to point out first is that that
method is very time consuming and you
can only do one fruit in about 30
minutes with two people so it's not
super labor efficient so our sample
sizes in 2022 were pretty small um I
increased the sample sizes in 2023 but
still um it was pretty small maybe like
five fruits for each thing throughout
the entire season so it maybe
interesting to have a lot more um labor
to look at this and have a lot more
fruit harvested and you could have maybe
nicer relationships to look at but um
the
self-pollinated bars are on the left and
the insect pollinated which would be the
ones that were not in any sort of
exclusion covering um are on the right
and in most of these
situations um the insect pollinated bars
are significantly higher fruit set
proportion than the self-pollinated
which is a really nice uh result to show
that pollinators are important for fruit
set however um you can see that you can
still have a really nicely set
marketable fruit at as low is
38% fertilization for albon which is
pretty Stark um that's less than half
percent or less than half of the total
ofes fertilized will still make a
marketable fruit and only marketable
fruit were analyzed in these uh uh
experiments so albian is really nice and
flexible if maybe you don't have access
to pollinators or a really nice habitat
or you just want to do a lot of
protective covering to protect your
marketable
yields so uh to discuss a few key
findings the exclusion cover yielded
much more marketable fruit but lower
fertilization rates this seems pretty
paradox oxcal and confusing but the way
I like to think of it is that it's a
sort of tradeoff for the grower to look
at especially in albian if they are in
an environment with high pest pressure
high precipitation High disease pressure
exclusion covering or low tunnels may be
really nice to protect their crop and
reduce maybe chemical inputs and albian
is still capable of self-producing a
really nice set fruit however if you had
maybe access to a really nice um amount
of IPM and labor and um management of a
lot of these different challenges and
you didn't want to have the exclusion
tunnels up all of the time uh insect
pollination will most definitely
increase your fruit set and also likely
your marketable yield percentages so I
think it's a a decision up to the grower
for what they can handle in their
operation uh total marketable yields
were highest in plants with established
vegetative growth and limited pest
pressure so these were often plug or
early start plants in exclusion netting
um and this I think likely is because
there is plenty of leaves available to
photosynthesize and also um enough root
establishment so that during the season
they had um enough resources to produce
really nice looking fruit instead of
having to compete between root uh leaf
and fruit development all at the same
time earlier in the
season and weather particularly
precipitation can have a very large
impact on marketable yields like I said
38% of the 2022 picking season which was
from the beginning of June to the end of
October and uh 57% of the 2023 season
which was from the end beginning of July
to the end of September um was impacted
by rainy
days and some conclusions while
protective varas can protect plants and
allow for greater yields insect
pollination is still significant for
good quality fruit
formation and as I mentioned earlier
pollinators did not move from the
flowering cover onto the strawberries um
and pest pressure increased with the
flowering cover both of which of these
um often resulted in lower Mark
yields and honeybees or apis maliss are
not the main pollinator of strawberry in
New York specifically in East itha but
rather there is a native Guild of bees
with lius confusus and laog glossom
species comprising the majority of the
pollinators in our East OCA
site so i' just like to thank some
people that uh this would not at all
have been possible without first of all
um Marvin for being a wonderful adviser
and helping me dream up this project um
Greg L and Heather grab for being
wonderful entomologist advisors and um
helpers in identifying all of my beads
Casper for doing basically um all
technical aspects of managing and
producing strawberries which are a very
labor intense crop to grow um Erica from
the stats cons Consulting unit who
helped me analyze a lot of my data and
make these really nice graphs that I was
able to show you and then uh the Cornell
Orchard interns from 2022 and 2023 um
strawberries require a lot of Labor and
without them I would not at all have
been able to do any of this work or
collect these samples so with that I
just want to thank you and I'll take any
questions you
have do you have any questions yeah any
sense how the pollinator deild
changes throughout New York State um so
I think in the inom department they're
doing a survey of what bees are present
in New York state in general um that may
have just been completed I also know
Heather for her PhD did this kind of
strawberry pollinator work at multiple
sites in New York state and so it may be
interesting to look at what she
collected but she was observing helus
confusus as the main strawberry
pollinator and laog glossom kind of in
the same cycles that I did um though she
did I think her study was over five
years at multiple sites so she has a
little bit more complicated of a guild
story but I think um the seasonality of
those bees is pretty that biologically
and so if those beads are present in
that environment it's likely they will
cycle through in that way if that
answers your question
yeah yeah Hannah I don't really know
anything about insect just doesn't make
sense you think it's possible that um
all the weather in 2023 like affected um
some of the
diversity breakdowns that you saw
because it's like if there were only so
many nice like good pollinating days or
something like you're going to have
everyone out there defin
people that's definitely likely like
there would be increased foraging
pressure on specific days um I would
handwave and say that's likely um I I
have no dat data to back that up but
from having to collect on very specific
days um yeah there was a a good amount
of activity on those days compared to
the previous year where it seemed they
were a little more
flexible
yeah uh
yeah
also but the species that youve
any um not that I know of they're mostly
solitary and um keep to themselves when
they're foraging it's not common for
bees to be really aggressive when
they're foraging unless like one
accidentally lands on top of the other
and kind of Spooks them um so I wasn't
really aware of any antagonistic
relationships during foraging or nesting
um there is one be that I did not
collect that Heather collected called um
the Genesis fides and it's a parasitoid
and so that's obviously an antagonistic
relationship where it's a parasitoid of
other bees um but the ones that I
observed I don't think any have
antagonist
relationships yeah I wanted you
speculate a little bit on on the rad
cover so you use one type of rad cover
and it was down pretty much the whole
time yes um if you could speculate could
you uh maybe design an additional
modification to that rad cover or think
of a management system that might allow
for better pollination but still give
you some of the benefits of insect
exclusion maybe sh yeah um if I were to
design a sort of row cover
implementation for this area I would
probably start with um exclusion netting
and like a plastic cover really early in
the season and plant much earlier so
that way you have temperature protection
and you've pushed your season up much
earlier into the spring and then as
temperatures begin to warm up you could
change take your plastic off and then
you could do uh venting I guess for a
few hours at peak times of the day day
um maybe for 3 or 4 hours in the middle
of the day on nice sunny days for
pollination and then if you had rainy
days or um maybe you had been scouting
and you saw a lot of pest pressure you
could keep those down and um protect
your fruit from pests and then later in
the season I know you've done some work
with different coverings you could
change your plastic for cold protection
and also for um increased
uh light quality um in the later part of
the Season that could increase uh the
amount of photosynthates produced and um
yeah I think it would it would have to
be definitely labor dependent though
because you would need somebody to go
and lift and change and do those sorts
of things so if you could I think doing
the peak hours of the day on a sunny day
might be really nice in terms of Labor
um instead of having to do multiple days
or go out at strange times of day are
the my bugs dial or nocturnal or know um
I don't know uh if the like cycle of
their activity is known I don't
personally know um but I I mean I've
seen I saw a great amount of activity
during the day um with nymphs and
females out um it would be interesting
to see if they were less active at night
um but they seem to be active at the
same times that pollinators are active
and so you have to start figuring out
some tradeoffs of how to manage tarnish
plant bug while
also allowing your beneficials to do
what they need to do to your fuit yeah
that was another really challenging
thing with marketable yields was we were
trying to pick uh chemical Intervention
when the action threshold was surpassed
to Target the tarnish plant bug and also
not pick really aggressive chemicals
that could hurt be populations because
that could be felt weeks and weeks out
if you par harmed a nest or something
like that
so
yeah
yeah how
you yeah so the USDA has two different
types of like marketable conditions uh
number one and number two they often are
by weight so they have to be at least
five grams fully red or 90% red they can
be a little pink um no physical
deformation so they have to be a typical
like heart-shaped strawberry shape and
they can't have any physical or
damage uh the seil still have to be on
so there's like very clear marketability
guidelines per the USDA for selling at
certain grades um so I was operating
usually at the US number two line which
was a little bit smaller fruit and um I
think they allow for 70% red so that we
could pick a little bit earlier um
yeah but that that was the criteria that
I
used ask IFA has any questions yeah uh
is there anybody on Zoom that has
anything to say I've got a question sure
um I don't know this but do strawberry
Growers typically use hives in their
field do they bring hives out um it
depends on the environment I would say
that if you had acres and acres and
Acres of strawberries and you were
really really needing pollination people
may bring out honeybees um or you may be
more inclined to just plant a more
self-compatible variety so that you
don't even need to worry about that um
Marvin do you know like in California is
it common to bring hives I don't see too
many
hives I know it's common like blueberri
is definitely um some other hives that
really need that activ
or uh Acres or plantings that need that
activity but I don't know that in terms
of small farms it's uh something that
people commonly do however if you were a
new berry grower or a new farmer and you
weren't familiar about what people were
doing and you have heard honey bees are
great pollinators and they're in Decline
and I should do something about that I'm
going to have hives um that could maybe
persist a misconception that wouldn't be
helpful and could be a cost that a
grower does not need to pay for
necessarily are there any other
questions well thank you
thanks this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu